salud en directo América de France 24
Marina sardinha con nosotros en el
estudio Marina bienvenida feliz
miércoles vamos a hablar Marina de una
dolencia que afecta más de 1500 millones
de personas en todo el mundo y estamos
hablando de la pérdida de audición
estamos prestando atención a esta
enfermedad Marina a la que cada vez
estamos más expuestos con todos los
audífonos que utilizamos cuando vamos a
salir a bailar por ejemplo Buenos días
Raúl Pues si algunos lo llaman la
epidemia silenciosa valga la redundancia
Y es que cada vez estamos expuestos a
ruidos más altos como bien dices sobre
todo los jóvenes debido a los audífonos
debido a también a la contaminación
auditiva de las ciudades y esto está
generando una pérdida de audición
generalizada y de la que tenemos que
prestarle atención también como un tema
de salud pública precisamente para
hablar de esto está con nosotros el
doctor Oscar Franco que es director del
departamento de salud pública de la
universidad Buenos días doctor y gracias
por estar de nuevo en France 24 con
nosotros lo primero Según la OMS la
pérdida de audición en algún tipo de
grado afecta a 1500 millones de personas
en todo el mundo se espera que sea el
doble para 2050 sólo en las Américas 217
millones de personas ya sufren esta
afectación que esto supone el 22% de la
población total estamos ante una
epidemia silenciosa
yo creo que sí es que estamos viendo la
combinación de múltiples factores que
están generando este problema que no se
le ha prestado suficiente atención pero
que con el tiempo yo creo que puede
generar un problema más importante a
nivel social y es que tenemos por un
lado el envejecimiento de la población y
la edad es uno de los principales
factores
tenemos la polución auditiva cada vez
más contaminación lugares de
entretenimiento en aviones buses en las
calles y también tenemos los avances
tecnológicos que nos ha permitido que
con un dispositivo móvil o con otro
dispositivo personal podamos estar
permanentemente Oyendo música con
auriculares y esto ha generado un riesgo
y una disminución en la capacidad
auditiva de la población doctor los
saludo buena mañana y feliz 2000 23 le
pregunto entonces que es esta pérdida
auditiva oculta o sin aptopatía coclear
Cómo podemos detectar si estamos
teniendo daños en nuestro sistema
auditivo doctor
sí muchas veces esto es un problema que
cuando se detecta es un poco tarde
porque las personas no se pueden dar
cuenta de que lo tienen Y es que las
personas lo que experimentan es que
tienen una dificultad para entender el
habla en lugares donde hay ruido o
cuando varias personas están conversando
al mismo tiempo cuando van a evaluarse
en el audiograma o en la evaluación del
especialista se encuentra que la
audición está adecuada Entonces el
problema es que la transmisión entre las
células que llevan el sonido al cerebro
y la interpretación de estos sonidos Se
va disminuyendo se va viendo afectada y
la gente pues no se da cuenta que está
teniendo este problema lo que estamos
viendo Es que esto está aumentando por
esa polución acústica que ocurre en
nuestro medio ambiente y también por el
uso de los dispositivos personales y los
auriculares
doctor y además de entorpecer la
comunicación esta pérdida auditiva que
otras enfermedades puede acarrear
también la exposición al ruido no como
se sabe que puede derivar en depresiones
en insomnio incluso también algunos
estudios señalan que hay un riesgo de
enfermedad cardíaca de hasta un 8%, nos
puedes contar un poco más de esto
Sí por supuesto Y es que va por varias
fases al principio puede generar una
frustración una frustración que se puede
traducir en un aislamiento social que se
puede traducir en una depresión que
posteriormente puede llevar a un déficit
cognitivo y se considera también como
uno de los factores de riesgo
principales de demencia a largo plazo
Nosotros también en estudios que hemos
hecho hemos encontrado una asociación
entre factores de riesgo del corazón o
enfermedades cardiovasculares con la
pérdida auditiva sin embargo no está
claro que causa uno o el otro y es
posible que la pérdida auditiva
una alarma o una detección de un proceso
de envejecimiento que está ocurriendo de
manera no muy clara clínicamente pero
que está afectando el sistema
cardiovascular y que está afectando
nuestra capacidad nuestra fragilidad
como se podría llamar y nuestro
envejecimiento saludable doctor también
otro estudio de British
señala que más de mil millones de
jóvenes pueden estar en riesgo de perder
la audición en parte también lo
atribuyen por lo que estamos hablando el
aumento de positivos de escucha personal
o el mal uso de estos audífonos por
ejemplo escuchar música con audífonos a
niveles muy altos no Cuáles son las
consecuencias para salud física también
mental y Cómo afecta la educación de los
más jóvenes
y quizás agregar Raúl también que mucha
gente va a conciertos o que va a eventos
en los que hay mucho ruido y
generalmente después de esas posiciones
ese ruido tan alto se puede detectar ya
una pérdida auditiva que realmente se
recupera pero que de manera silenciosa
permanece y va afectando la capacidad
auditiva y esto genera no solamente esa
pérdida de la capacidad auditiva sino
nuevamente una disminución en la
capacidad de concentrarse o un problema
como dolores de cabeza y que puede
traducirse como el aislamiento social y
problemas en el rendimiento académico de
las personas
doctor también hemos visto sabemos que
las personas que están más expuestas a
estos ruidos suelen ser personas de
entornos y de recursos más bajos del sur
global que viven en lugares más
hacinados también como afecta estas
inequidades a la salud auditiva de las
personas y qué se está haciendo desde la
salud pública no Cuáles son las
recomendaciones que ustedes los médicos
les hacen a los estados para tratar de
este tema como un tema de salud pública
si este es un tema salud pública
completamente la Organización Mundial
sacó recomendaciones en el 2015 que
necesitábamos tomar acciones y esas
acciones tienen que ocurrir a varios
niveles no solamente las prácticas
personales es tratar de utilizar los
auriculares pero tratar de oír la música
o lo que estamos oyendo la televisión o
un sonido mucho más bajo también el
estilo de vida se ha visto relacionado
con la capacidad auditiva comer bien
dormir bien hacer ejercicio de otro lado
estar la reducción de la de la polución
acústica a través de la construcción o
del tráfico o en aeropuertos y también
está en la parte laboral donde hay que
reducir la exposición en los niveles y
la duración para los las personas que
están trabajando
esas políticas se han recomendado se han
sacado se saben sin embargo la
implementación de esas políticas en
diferentes países pues es diferente y
muchas personas en el aspecto laboral
Estás siendo protegidas suficientemente
y están expuestas a perder esa capacidad
auditiva a través del tiempo
doctor Muchísimas gracias como siempre
por su tiempo y por estar con nosotros
en estas mañanas de directo América de
Francia 24 un abrazo
un abrazo y gracias Marina también por
supuesto por acompañarnos acá y nosotros
saludamos a nuestro segundo invitado el
día